first up he is national correspondent
for the Atlantic whose current cover
story is the tragic decline of the
American military Jim fallows Jim hey
great pleasure as you go how you do
appreciate it well I read your article
yeah I mean you're you're pretty brave
guy to call Nicole at what you did the
tragic decline your must be worried that
the American Isis is going to get you
well it's the among the hardening
reactions I've gotten thousands and
thousands of messages mainly from people
in the military mainly saying thanks for
pointing out these issues and you know
it is such a sacred cow the military I
mean I say the same thing here for years
on this show I mean I've talked about
this and what bothers me is that they do
a little three-card Monte trick if we
say if we criticize the Pentagon
spending defense contractors they turn
it into well you're denigrating the
troops and those are two different
things aren't they oh of course
and the what struck me most that the
argument is trying hardest to get across
here is anything we take seriously and
know whether it's the school system the
medical system right the press or
whatever we know that it has good and
bad aspects the military we don't act
that way anymore you have to treat
everybody as heroes without them get on
the airplanes early we give them a
salute at halftime then we don't think
about the jobs we're setting them to do
the weapons they I mean I support the
troops I think we all do but we do treat
them almost like we treat children now
our precious little angels where you
can't say anything bad and once again a
very interesting thing I've heard from
so many soldiers and Marines have
written back saying that when they hear
thank you for your service we support
the troops what they want to say is you
want to thank me for your service you
know vote on the wars we're going to be
a citizen right ancient of these job
yeah
I've always said the same thing if you
want to support the troops don't send me
to this pointless military stalemate
exactly okay so let's just get down to
brass tacks what do we spend now you see
you basically say a trillion dollars
yeah and I think the Pentagon baseline
budget is almost 600 and then yet
another couple of hundred billion for
the wounded teachers etc I'm coming back
nuclear that's a different Department I
don't think you're even including
Homeland Security no I'm not so it's
about a trillion dollars he's just have
the military per se plus Russians and
and what but adding Homeland Security
it's even more it's more to keep the
monsters away yep and this is how much
more than what every other country spent
well the the most interesting contrast I
think is our economy is of course the
biggest in the world China has you know
some so it'll reach there some time we
spend twice as large a share of our GDP
about four percent as the rest of the
world does on average so we're the
biggest economy we spend twice as much
as much as next ten or fifteen countries
together it's by far the biggest input
of money of any country in the world
right and you're not afraid to use the
word Chicken Hawk and you're also not
afraid to say that the war in
Afghanistan and the war in Iraq we lost
and you'll never hear a president say
that of course Obama starts every
speeches every president does State of
the Union is strong you make the point
no buy any real measure we lost those
wars right and and there are battles we
won all the way along but if you look
anybody who writes the history of this
era will say the biggest strategic
mistake we made was invading Iraq you
know without provocation a dozen years
ago and this has been a decade plus of
strategic defeat for the United States I
think in the piece I used the line that
the trillions of dollars we spent on
these Wars 2 or 3 trillion nobody really
knows might as well have been burned for
the good they've done for the United
States for the world
we also make the point that the only
real strategic victory was killing bin
Laden right which we could have done
years earlier it's good that it happened
at all but the one of the many things
that went wrong with the war in Iraq was
the diversion of the effort to rout bin
Laden his troops from Tora Bora and so
that was when he was on the run early it
took another decade to get it right
I mean if I've asked this of panels
before if we had only reinforced the
cockpit doors on airplane right and
killed bin Laden and not done all the
other stuff wouldn't we be in better
shape now we sure would and I think
people would have this kind of
discussion it would be debated in
presidential campaigns as hardly as it
all would be a subject of common
knowledge if the public at large was
connected somehow to the military if you
take everybody who's fought in all the
wars the last dozen years at any time
it's three quarters of one percent of
the population they're twice as many
farm families as there are people people
in the military now I mean the ironic
thing is that when people say well we
should never cut the military of course
they're people who never look into how
much we spend on the military what that
money is going towards really spending
that much makes us weaker we don't have
money to spend on building our nation
right home we don't have the
infrastructure of other countries we
don't have a lot of things other
countries have because we waste 20
percent of our budget on basically
fighting Russia in 1978 it's it's true
and in the you know aircraft what do we
have what 10 aircraft carriers we have
yes we have large you have more aircraft
carriers anybody else the Chinese have
one they bought a used one from Ukraine
that's gonna be a long time before
that's a threat you know politicians
have have known that that the main way
you can do infrastructure or investment
the United States is to call it defense
you know doe-eyed Eisenhower with the
National Defense interstate highway act
and all the DARPA which got the internet
going it would be so much more efficient
with if we could actually invest in
these things in the long run without the
leaky loose eyes attention eyes and air
he's the one who said we have to watch
out for the military-industrial complex
if he made that speech today he would
probably ask to apologize for no Bill
O'Reilly would call him a pinhead if if
anybody goes back to read that farewell
address Eisenhower gave in January 1960
it is incredible because he warns about
things that 50 plus years later are the
reality of having the impact of military
contracting of military shaping foreign
policy that this was something he as a
former commander of the greatest
fighting force in the history of the
world was saying this was a caution to
be this was a caution to observe funny
in his era and and the error that
followed when they were talking about
his era World War two you could make fun
of the military television and movies
were full of funny military people
sergeant bilko Hogan's Heroes
McHale's Navy normil Gomer Pyle right
you could never do those shows today
because it shows military people could
be less than saintly and I think that is
a crucial point that's the sign of a
country comfortable enough with its
military to make fun of it to know that
like any other human institution it was
good and bad and preposterous and Noble
and collectively it was great but it had
a lot of people who weren't great and
now you know it in these twelve years of
war we've removed commanders for sexual
peccadilloes and for leaking to the
press but not for these battlefield
failures that have been so terrible for
the country and for the world all right
Jim thank you so much for being here
thank you very got a chance to read it
[Applause]